is that your CA de buri pal heroin this
may be a slick piece of video propaganda
but it's message is deeply chilling and
you wish to be resurrected with the dust
from Villa Baca for still in your lungs
but you wish to be resurrected showing
your wounds where you sacrifice from
allah azza wajal the vast majority of
law-abiding Muslims just like those in
the wider community will view this with
a mix of disgust and anger but it's not
aimed at them this is a blatant attempt
by Isis to persuade a minority of young
impressionable men to take up arms for
the terror group and we will go to air
up in a few days and we will fight their
battle and come back and we will even go
to Jordan and Lebanon with no problems
well of our sheykh wants to send us it's
not just that these young men are urging
others from the West to join their fight
it's the claim those delivering that
rallying call themselves from the very
countries they're trying to recruit from
Bangladesh from Iraq from Cambodia
Australia UK among those speaking on the
13 minute long video or three men who
claim to have traveled to Syria from
Britain my brothers and sisters you need
to look to the hadith of the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu Selim and the man
on the left here is he claims one of two
Australians among this group the caption
claims he was later martyred while
fighting in Syria these videos won't
affect the overwhelming majority of
British and Western Muslims but they
don't need to you just need a handful at
a time you just need a very small
minority and that's more minority if you
take that from the UK from the rest of
the West it becomes a larger fighting
force and that's the worrying factor for
the authorities here this video only
compounds their concerns about the risk
to national security from returning Isis
fighters we've seen this all before less
than a decade ago young idealistic
British men travelling for jihad in
Afghanistan and Pakistan trained in
terror camps and sent back to the UK to
plot attacks against their own
countrymen I know how you feel when I
used to live in the heart can feel the
the security services already estimate
around 450 British jihadis are currently
fighting in Syria and Iraq with every
new one who answers the call to arms
the authorities believe there will be an
inevitable increase in the threat back
home mark White Sky News